As opposed to just fighting.
This is the really interesting thing about brave is as opposed to just fighting
in and being treated like an ad blocker, you're providing an alternate.
There's a,
there's a philosophical idea here that might change the nature of the internet
with a basic attention token. Yes.
Maybe what is basic attention, token bat and how does it.
Okay. I'll tell the story first by saying how I came to it.
I realized for a long time at Firefox,
we were dependent on the school search deal. And I thought, you know,
w now the Chrome's out. Maybe that's going to go away. And they'd just,
at some point, Google will say, you know, Firefox, you know, like old yeller,
you saved me from the rabid beast. Now you have to shoot you in the head. Yeah.
Done your job. Sad, but true goodbye.
And what can we do? And I think this, most of all, it doesn't know what to do.
This is something that I couldn't solve there and I don't think they can solve,
but I thought,
why is the browser that sort of passive servant of these big tech companies?
Why is it a blind runtime for ad tech JavaScripts, including from Google?
Why doesn't it block some? And if it blocks them,
why can't it reconnect users,
readers fans with publishers, creators websites, uh,
why can't it help people make direct payments or even possibly get an ad
revenue share for private ads that are placed in the browser?
The ads are all placed in the browser.
Some people will have this sort of model that the server's painting the ad into
some flash, uh,
combined package or into some giant image. And then it all gets sent down.
That's not how it works.
All the ads you see on the web are placed in your browser by calling out to
various ad tech partners and Googles among them.
And so if you block those scripts, you, you break the,
the advertising flow of money from the brands and their
agencies to the publishers.
And if you want to reconnect it directly with the user,
you have limited choices. The user generally,
isn't going to sign up with an ACH bank connection or a credit card.
The publisher isn't going to sign up the user acceptance as a subscriber,
and then they're going to overcharge you because they want you to cross
subsidize all the content and buy more than you read and all that stuff.
And how many people are doing great,
who are big names like New York times and the Washington post.
But how many subscriptions are you as a user going to pay for?
This is why startups like Tony Hale scroll are trying to do a portable
subscription system.
By the way, just on a small tangent there, even the New York times,
it's really annoying how difficult it is to subscribe.
There's way too many clicks.
They don't make it easy. And I had friends a few years ago.
I think they fixed this who would pay for the paper and then they'd go online
and they get charged for the digital. And they, there was no break.
There was no connection between them, but publishers are not that technical.
And there, they can't all get you to subscribe.
You can't have a thousand subscriptions. So for a long time,
people talked about micro payments.
That was Blendle and another ones which came to the U S but didn't grow.
And I thought,
if you have just a browser and it's protecting you by blocking all this ad tech
tracking junk,
it can provide you an option that uses cryptocurrency to let you support your,
your, your favorite sites and even YouTube channels.
And that we prototyped with Bitcoin.
And that meant the user had to be of means to contribute and willing to
contribute, but it could be done on the Bitcoin blockchain.
And it could be fairly efficient,
even though Bitcoin went through a period when we had this prototype running in
2016, into 2017,
where Bitcoin was very congested and very slow to confirm,
and the fees got very high. Um,
and a lot of users who were not Bitcoin maximalist or even experienced, we,
we helped them out by embedding a Coinbase buy widget,
and they had the income to buy, but it was hard. It was like,
I'll do I buy a $5 a month? But the fee is like four 50.
I better buy in larger batches. Right? Then they're like,
I don't want to own that much Bitcoin. So it became this, this painful thing.
And the real idea that I had of private ads to pay the user of rev share,
couldn't be realized alone in that kind of system,
in these cryptocurrency systems, especially with the blockchain,
we switched to a theorem, you can have smart contracts.
The Bitcoin system is not turning complete.
So what you can do with the script is more limited,
but you can still do sort of clever things. Um, even with Bitcoin script,
what we wanted to do was sort of a three sided ecosystem. We wanted users,
creators, or publishers and advertisers,
and we wanted the advertisers to put money in just like they do today,
but without going through the Googles and the app nexuses and all these other ad
tech companies, because those companies take out a huge cut.
The guardian in the UK once did an experiment for months.
They bought out their own ad space.
They put in the pound and they were paid 30 pens,
70% was coming out to the intermediary vendors they were using.
Um, um, and that's like the opposite of what the app store does.
The app store takes 30% and gives the publisher 70%.
So pretty broken in the old days of the Superstation TBS, the media,
um, owner would get 85%.
So these splits have become really unbalanced in the middle players.
The ad tech vendors are taking out way too much money, and they're,
they're doing something worse, which has been noticed there. They're letting,
um, not just the malware vendors, but also the ad fraud side,
which fakes the publishers and clickbait merchants,
uh, come in and steal traffic from good sites.
Because once you have a certain audience identified at one site,
Jason Calacanis told me this about his experience with,
I guess it was in gadget, uh, what site he was running.
But once he started using, uh,
an ad partner that was sharing his audience information across multiple sites,
he saw his competitors stealing all his traffic.
And then what's worse is the clickbait sites that just have much cheaper rates,
steal all of that traffic. And that facilitates, you know, fraud facilitates,
um, fake news, all sorts of problems. So Frey blocks it.
And then we give users the ability to give back and because invested the basic
attention token and Ethereum, we can do this, three-way split,
and we can give users a share of the revenue. And if they want to take it out,
they can now unfortunately for us, and for all of blockchain,
the regulators are saying, we're going to have to know who you are. There's,
there's the treasury department's, uh, FinCEN, uh,
agency. There's the office of foreign asset controls, OFAC. Um, there's the,
um, you know,
other regulators in the federal government that take a very dark look at things
like money laundering and sending money to someone named Osama bin Ladin.
So compliance starts to come in and even now they're threatening for pure
Bitcoin sending to some address. If you're a Coinbase,
you're going to have to know who's at that address. You're gonna the actual.
Identities of people involved now.
With Coinbase members, you sign up and they know you,
and they comply with regulations. There are regulated money services, business,
uh, and, um,
but if somebody is using their own self custody,
so-called self custodial wallet where they have the hardware private key,
and they're not named. And they want to send to that address.
Our friends in the fed government are talking about requiring at some threshold,
knowing who that is. So yeah.
Some thresholds that's unreasonable. It's not that big. Um, yeah.
I don't know how this will play out. I think crypto is here to stay.
I think the beauty of being able to send peer to peer without any bank in the
middle of that, and, you know,
huge wire charge and two day delay and all that nonsense, it's beautiful.
I've used it and I love it, but we're pregnancies to brave about crypto.
And we realized that anything like a revenue split,
we can't facilitate without being licensed in a certain way.
And it requires knowing who the user is.
So our default mode doesn't know who the user is.
It instead imputes to the user's browser,
some of the revenue and allows that browser to steer it back to the
creators. And we do have to identify the creators,
but as things improve and you know, who knows how it'll play out,
there should come a day when this, this full vision could be done more, uh,
fully on a blockchain,
but regulations and the practicalities of today's blockchains,
which are not that fast, um, and not anonymous over time.
You fingerprint yourself over time. Uh, we do some of this with the browser.
So one of the ideas of the basic attention token is to make a
hybrid system that's stronger than blockchain alone.
It's the browser and the blockchain and the browser is this trusted end point
software. It's this universal app. Everyone uses browsers,
the bigger the screen, the more you're in the browser. And unless you install,
you know, fat clients for things, um, I use Slack on, on Mac iOS and it's,
it's like a browser it's based on, uh, electron framework we used to use.
And it's just, it's not that great. I, I,
some people at brave use Slack in brave as a.
In the browser. Yeah. Browser. Yeah. I use that often. Yeah. And I noticed that.
The iPad, I use apps less, um, the smaller, the screen, you know,
the browser got handicapped by Apple and Android, both. And it also, uh,
you know, it can be slower or not have the right affordances,
your interface with, uh, the security, uh, limited API APIs,
but in principle with the right permission,
and you can make the web browser just as good as any app,
you make it be a super app. And that's part of our mission at brave.
So we want to have the economics.
I got captured by these big tech companies through tracking and through social
networks. We want to block that for your own safety,
and then let you opt into a cleaner world where you keep your data defended in
your browser, and you can actually realize value from it.
So the way our ad system works, I mentioned that being private,
but how does that work? We don't see your data at all.
All browsers are sort of the mother of all data feeds your history,
all your searches, that all engines,
each engine sees the queries you send to it, but it doesn't see the others,
but the browser sees them all machine learning in the browser that you can opt
into, can study all that in a very complete way and do a better job than Google.
This Google has, you know,
cookie and scripts across the web from occurring DoubleClick. They have YouTube,
they have Android, they have search, which is still their big revenue line,
but they don't see everything. The browser sees everything.
And if it can do a good job locally, and this is not advanced machine learning,
this is not TensorFlow. This is like, SVMs now native bays. Um,
then you can match intense signals.
Intent signals from those data feeds, searches the queries, the history,
how much you're scrolling down the page, uh, how much you read it, a search,
it's all blind browser algorithm.
We don't see that data and then pick the best ad from a fixed catalog per day.
And the catalog is fixed across a large population per day.
And it only updates once a day because new offers come in and the old ones,
his wire, sometimes every week or every month and that catalog,
and there can be many such catalogs is sold by our direct sales team.
And so we're,
we're making an anonymous audience available to advertisers without the
advertisers tracking them. Instead, each browser is,
there's a little machine learning system. That's picking the best catalog entry.
Now the catalog is not the ads. Those are big, right? It's a video or a webpage.
It's just the link to an edge cache. And there are many such edge caches.
We're not trying to protect them from seeing your IP address.
It's not really feasible. We could use Tor, but we don't yet. Um,
and some keywords about the app. So it's basically like metadata and a link.
And that's what the catalog consists of.
And that's what the machine learning picks, right?
The machine learning is learning about you specifically locally. Yes.
In order to choose from the catalog of different ads,
it couldn't possibly be like a multi-billion dollar.
Isn't this taken on the Google ad ad. So like what, I mean,
one question to ask that there seems to be some really profound ideas here that
are different than what the internet has grown up to be.
If brave or something like brave.
The idea is a fundamental philosophical ideas.
Underlying brave went out and runs 95% of the internet.
How does that change? Uh, the what,
what are the major things he changes about the internet? So social networks,
and then the creatives, like YouTube creators, all that kind of stuff. So.
Let's talk about that. First of all, what brave gets 95%.
I'm going to demand a recount because I won't believe it. I don't know. I think,
uh,
we're trying to put things into web standards that can be standardized across
browsers.
So the main value of brave will be the trust users have in us and our ability to
give the best deal to users. So 70% of the gross ad revenue we give to the user.
And if they go through that KYC process, as I mentioned, they can take it out.
They can also give it back. Like it takes them out,
give the rest back and they can add basic attention tokens to give back.
Some of them turn off the ads because it just don't like ads,
but they put in $20 a month. I believe [inaudible] does that.
And that's very generous because the browser is just anonymously based on his
browsing sort of keeping score on how much time he spent on this video,
on that website. And if those sites verify in sort of a,
like getting a domain certificate fashion, they can get paid,
they can get a part of his $20 a month. So that vision could go big.
And if it does, I hope it's across mobile browsers.
I don't know that they'll all compete well on the quality of the ads,
the quality of the ad blocking and tracking protection. Those,
those are subject to competition. It'll take a while to standardize them,
but I think that would be a better world. It would have less counterparty risk,
fewer fee takers in the middle, really just the browser. We're taking 30%, um,
sort of the app tours, app store split. And if we get bigger,
maybe we can take even less social networks creators. If you look at YouTube,
as a lot of them are the Indies that are getting some size are getting
sponsorship deals. Uh, they're, they're using Patrion.
They're encouraging people to subscribe and give them regular money through
Patrion, but that's centralized your Patrion. So there's censorship hazards.
There's a 5% fee. What if that were web standard?
What if brave pioneer at first?
And we took 3% and we did it in a way that was three-year
browsers. So we couldn't sensor it as brilliant. Yeah.
It could be standardized across browsers can like explore a come in again. And,
uh.
I think protocols are easy to copy and that they're meant to be interpretable.
So it's,
there's a risk there and the loyal users might be tricked into leaving you,
or they might, because of that distribution power,
you might end up getting stomped. Um, I don't know. I can't predict the future.
I think anti-trust is back on the case finally, in the U S and,
and certainly in Europe, DG comp is doing its thing.
So I'm hopeful that we'll have a period of innovation. Uh, you know,
people were talking like Elizabeth Warren was talking about breaking up the tech
tech companies very clearly. Um,
now she didn't win and I suspect that won't happen,
but I also suspect that Google might be smart enough to see they should do
something more than just put privacy perfume on Chrome.
They should maybe get rid of click or something, divest something.
I don't know it might happen.
So,
so brave might inspire Google to completely change the way they're doing things,
right.
We're already doing something you may have read about called the privacy sandbox
or, um, flock, which they have this bird metaphor going. Um,
turtledove, um, fledge. But these, these,
these systems have been very, Google-y kind of over-engineer. And yet,
depending on differential privacy, which has weakness over time,
if you know how that works, it's kind of injecting noise to hide you in a,
in a crowd. But over time, an adversary can pull you out of the crowd.
This doesn't look like it's gonna become a standard like Apple, brave Mozilla.
We're not going to just say, Oh, Google, you saved us.
You've indebted the privacy sandbox. And we'll all just adopt it.
Not going to be that easy.
It's going to be more like pieces of what we do in brave,
this anonymous ad matching or the blind signature cryptography we use to confirm
the ad impressions. That's David chums.
You mentioned that could get standardized.
If that's some of that is being standardized.
Even Google is in favor of so-called trust tokens. What's your champion blind,
blind signature certs,
but they're not using them for ad confirmations because they don't want to blow
up their own business. Um, and they need to let some of the publishers,
they serve have other ad tech scripts on the page.
And so they're kind of caught, and this is something I realized doing great.
I thought what's, Google's innovator's dilemma apart from just, you know,
being mature and having trouble innovating it's that they have come to depend on
this ad tech system that has all these,
these vendors that are publishers rely on because publishers aren't technical
enough. And I feel for the publishers,
but I realized the users have to come first.
And if you give the users a better browser, that's faster,
then you'll get enough users to give back or support publishers,
the speed and the battery savings. And the data plan savings are significant.
There's so much bad JavaScript involved in ad tech.
If you block it and you sort of chop off the what's called the programmatic
waterfall, which chains a bunch of requests.
Yeah. That's one of the incredible things about brave,
I guess you're saying you should attribute it to the fact that the, the,
the message, our script, no offense. No, not my Suzy,
uh, is, uh, I mean, brave just feels faster. Even then,
I mean, Chrome was fast. And one of the things that it was like,
impressive is it, it,
it showed that browsers could be really fast and brave is even faster than that,
which is why.
So much. And it saves the network, which means data,
planet saves battery because of the radio consumes your battery when it's
running more to do those requests. And it's just stunning how many there are,
like some of my Google friends were like, Oh, that's just that bad site.
They'll fix it. And you actually do a survey of webpages. That's like,
mostly like that.
I know Google or Google engineers could make everything super efficient,
but they can't, especially in antitrust court do it.
They cannot take over all the publishers and do that.
They're trying with accelerated mobile profile amp. They're trying to pull,
the publishers are like, Oh, you poor publishers.
Don't know how to make your pages fast. Put them on our amp system.
We'll give you extra placement in the search carousel.
That's an antitrust problem for one, but it's also publishers.
We talked to hate it because it degrades their brand.
Now they look like a gig writer wrote a piece.
That's got Google's framing and amp URL on top of it.
And they're trying to fix that too,
but it just looks like a Google's board defying all these publishers and they
don't want to be plugged into the Borg cube.
They want to build up their own brand and have loyal readers. So, you know,
I'm in favor of giving the users power to help all the
publishers in the little platoons and the creators.